for years I've been treating the hawk  like he's some kind of disease something  to get rid of  but then I start looking at him as the  cure 18 months in the gamble lab I put  the brains and the Brawn together  and now they give me best of both worlds  excuse me mr. Holt yes Julie can we get  a photo 100% little person come on step  bomb do you mind okay thanks say green  [Music]  you want to grab one with me I'm ant-man  your Hulk fans wait they don't know  nobody nobody to know he wants you wants  to take a picture with their look he's  even saying no he doesn't I get along  the kid but you I don't want a picture  with he's gonna feel very happy to know  you feel bad no great kids thank you  very much Oh